dom phillips's work took him to some of
south america's most remote locations he
would send his family videos and
pictures of his whereabouts but on
sunday he and his guide disappeared
i am very anxious i am
very
desperately worried
i am hopeful too because you have to be
that's all you have
yeah but our worry is that they have
been they've been abducted by somebody
who uh who wanted to silence the
the the exposure that they were bringing
to illegal activities in the area
in el des dom who was fluent in spanish
and portuguese was highlighting the
impact deforestation was having on
indigenous communities in the amazon for
a new book
the current brazilian government is keen
to exploit the the rainforest further
and therefore um
exposing um
illegal logging is not necessarily
something that the government might
might be comfortable about the brazilian
army has been sent to the jivari region
of amazona state to try to find the men
dom's brazilian wife alessandra is
waiting for news
in a video she said even if i don't find
the love of my life alive we must find
them please
don's family think drug traffickers had
also been operating in the area we need
everything thrown at this it's an urgent
situation
and i want i want the eyes of the world
on it he's a bright star and
highlighting spotlighting this area he's
full of vitality i see him you know as a
he's my older brother i look up to him i
love him
she hopes that british officials are
doing all they can to help too
lisa dowd sky news lancaster